皆さんこんにちは大妻中なこと学校3年な子と思う派です
スゴ突然なんですけど
最近の若者は物を知らないっていうフレーズ
聞いたことありますよねきっと私このフレーズすごい嫌いで言われるとすごいイライラ
しちゃうんですけど今日はこんなフレーズをもう言われないようにしようよっていう
ことを言い確定
どうやってを得ないようにするかって言ったら私たちに会の若い世代が社会も
問題に興味を持って
そこについて知っていくちょっとでもいいから小さいアクションを起こしていくって
いうことでもうこれをれない谷中を作ろうっていう話をします
でこれもすごいはまた唐突なんですけど皆さんの中でイジメをしたことある人いますか
ね
だがこれを見ている人の中には少ないと思うんですけど
差別をしたことはありますかって言ったらどうですかね
あの
よく売っどこまで格別でどこからが差別化っていう議論があると思うんですけど私は
区別に感情が乗ったら差別だと思っているんですねデータけど人間っていうのは最後に
引きりきりきもの違いを認識できるきょんだからどうしてもその区別したのに対して
感情が乗っかったりとかその人が持っている個人のイメージが乗っかってくるっていう
のは当然の声だと思うんですけどでもその当然の行為が差別を生んでしまうこともある
ということをお伝えしたくて
ちょっと差別について話なんですけど
8を差別の根店には2つその人間の心理がされていて1個はない集団完売です
もう1個はスケープゴートってやつなんですけどえっと
来週ダンカンバイアスっていうのはこのスライドにもある通りなんですが
分かりやすくいうととと偏見の元凶みたいなものですって
えっと具体的ななんだろエピソードみたいに言ったらこう
あのクラスって頭いいけど経ず笠木血馬がそうだよね
でも落ちたのクラスはあってもある行きどうすごいみんな仲いいし jk 楽しいん
ですよねみたいな
その意味のないいい勝手に作った基準で会社と自分達の休館を比較して優劣をつけて
ぶたしゃん常によって他社も評価すべき
変顔見えなくなってしまうっていう現象のことを指します
でえっと一方でスケープゴートくっていうのは
た映画なんだろうなえっとあの子何考えてるかわかんないか気持ち悪いみたいな汗心根
言葉から始まってしまういじめっていうのもこれの典型的な例です
でえっとこの2つっていうのがその差別の県境にあるよって言ったんですけど
同時にその差別とか偏見から始まって肥満社会問題の
ポイントしてもあげられることですでなんだって背が差別について興味を持ったかって
いうと
小学校の時に体験した12が関係すると思っていて私は当時すごく好共感力が高い人
だったんですね
でその7相談されたらその子よりも私のほうが落ち込んじゃうみたいなこれ
あったんですけど
それがきっかけというか原因でいい子ぐりっ子だって言われてい者になれたんですけど
その時そのむやみに登場したりとか共感するっていうことは無責任なって思えちゃう
ことを知ったんですね
もうそれか私の原体験になって弱い立場の人を助けたいとか差別に興味を持ったし
し社会問題差別からマルイ社会問題っていうのに凄く興味の動きました
で中でも
私が興味を持って社会問題は外国人の道部者についての問題一
まぁ最近有名だと思うんですけどなんで興味を持ったかっていうと中学3年の時に
テレビで日系ブラジル人のおじいちゃんがインタビュー受けてたんですよユース番組で
その時に今生活がしんどく系とかっていう話をされていたんですけど私はその
インタビューを見てボロ泣きしたんですね
で
ニュースを見てなくっていうのはその時初めてだったので本当に自分にとってショック
な出来事だったんだなって思ったことが同時にいじられたこととかもあったが登場した
だけじゃ終わら経てはいけないなって思って自分が泣いたところでそのおじいちゃんは
何度も救われないじゃないですか
役に立たないからなくっていう講師タイプだがそれをすごく悔しく思って泡私は彼やの
ために何か行動を起こさなきゃっていう風に強く思ったのがきっかけです
でえっとその後何をしたかっていうとなず牛がこうしたんですね
なんで流学校したかって言ったらあの
彼らは日本っていうそのいここの家で一人で頑張っているわけだから
私も異国の地に行って頑張るっていう経験をした
ちょっとはカヤの気持ちがわかるんじゃないかなっていうふうに思ったから
留学を選んだんですけど実際に飛んでみて私があえて
田舎の白人の人が多いの家に行ったってこともあって黄色人種だから
サービスの会社になったんですよだけどその中にも私のことを理解しようとしてくれ
たりとか心回理想としてくれる人の
移転その人たちの存在っていうのが自分にとって本当に助けになるというかすぐになっ
たなっていうことを
開館したので帰国後は私は npo でも活動してるんですけど
なんですねやってるかって言ったら
私が留学中に救われたみたいにその自分のことを理解してくれようとしてる人がい
るっていうことを帰らに少しでもこうしました来て安直な考えだけで私も彼らを理解し
勝負してるよっていうことを伝えるために
そのかようなことを知るためにいってことも含めて npo でか
須藤をしていますでえっと
ちょっとその活動について話すんですけどあの主に黒神と呼ばれる方を対象に活動して
いるんですね支援のでえっとクルド人て聴いてどこの人って思う方が結構多いと思うん
ですけど私も加入前どこの人が知らなくてくるドっていう国はないんですね
この地図見てもらったら分かる
んですけどオレンジの部分に多く住んでるって言われていて1分
各地で差別とかダンスとかの対象になってしまってきた人たちのことを貸しますねっ
えっと彼らと実際に関わっていく中で私はいかに良いサザン9対応される人が入って
それを見過ごす人も多いかということを知ったんですけど今日はその
など私が聞いたエピソードの中でちょっと共有したいのがあるので一つお話しします
彼は20代でクルージング男性なんですけど
影響奥さんと3歳の息子さんと3人で日本に住んでたんですねっ
ねあの子の中で出色先をなくしてしまって
自国に帰りたいってなったんですけど僕さんと息子さんはもう帰りたんですよ
だけど彼は帰らなかったんですね何でかっていったら
パスポートを企業に取り上げられちゃってたからなんですけど
これパスポート取り上げバンダイって言ってすごく好
問題視されていることなんですけど
海洋を説明すると
農道さんのパスポートを雇ってる企業側が何か手続きに必要とかって言って取り上げて
するキープすちゃうっていう行為で何が問題かっていうとあーパスポートがないと
外国人の労働者の方っていうのはあのお引っ越しとか転職とかできないんですよ
手老活その際原子核を更新するためには今の薬医先との契約が終了したら絶対にその
新しい食先を提示しなきゃいけないんですけど
就職活動ができないから定食先も見つからなくて
あのう
非正規滞在状況とかオーバーステイって呼ばれてしまう
その日本にいること自体が違法っていう風になってしまって
まぁ結果収入源を得られないしでもパスポートもないから国も帰れないし凄く苦しい
生活を続けなきゃいけないっていう風になってしまうんですね
で私にお話ししてくれたからも
その問題に悩まされている1人だったんですけど
普段の私はその時すごく黄色を受けて実際に体験した人の話を聞いたのは初めてだった
から本当にこう大きな衝撃を受けたんですね
だけど同時にすごく彼に感謝して言って何でかっていったらあのう
npo で活動をしていても正直自分にこう私を選んで話しかけてくれる人って
なかなかいないんですよ
ってここ生だし役に立たなそうだからだけど彼が私に聞いてほしいって言ってしゃべっ
てくれていさらに
まあ自分はあのいじめられたことがあったから
人に見えに共感するっていうことは良くないと思ってたんですけどまぁその会の話を
聞いた私泣いちゃったんですね
でそのときに彼が私にん
あなたは人の話を聞くことで人の心を軽くすることができるねって言ってくれたんです
よ
それが本当に私にとって嬉しかったというか自分はその共感
自分の共感力っていうのをそれまではこれネガティブん
な方向にとらえていたけど自分のその強い共感力
っていう力があ
人の役に立つこともできるしポジティブな方向に使うことができるんだっていうふうに
思て彼の言葉にすごく自信をもらったんですよ
で何が言いたいかっていうとボランティア活動っていうとどうしてもこう与えるって
イメージがすごい強いかもしれないけど私にとってはそうではなくてこう
もらっているものの方が本当に大きいよっていうことが言いたいんですね
でこうやってあ何体験談を話していてもボランティア活動はなんか偽善的だって思う人
がいると思うんですよ
私みたいに高校生で npo でなんちゃらとかって行けると
通して大学受験のためでしょって思ってもいいと思うんです
よっ
だけど私はその考えを取っ払ってほしくて
あの別にチャリティー活動とかボランティア活動をしろっていうわけではないけどその
ボランティア活動をしたいって思ってる人がこうやりにくい世の中をつくっちゃうしか
ないと思ってて
どういうことかって言ったら慈善活動以降の偽善的だっていう考えがあることによって
そのチョップをボランティア活動を躊躇してしまう人がいると思うんですね
それ本当に良くないことだと思うんですよ
でこういう考え方が日本にある原因として私はその宗教気が池あげると思って言って
安納
このオレンジの部分このグラフのオレンジの部分見てもらったら分かると思うんです
けどって
大半の人が宗教を信仰してないじゃないですか
私も別に宗教特にメッシに品壊してないんですよ
だけどそのいわゆる寄付者率が高い国っていうのはアメリカだったリリース脱退
メンバーだったり
いっぱいあるけど全部その熱心に宗教を信仰しているっていう共通点があるんですね
じゃあああなんかその宗教嫌いってはに日本ではチャリティー文化が普及しなくても
いいのかって言ったらそうではないと思うんですよ
で皆さんにちょっとお話ししたいのが寄付とか署名っていうのは私たち若者が
席ん意志を示すその数少ない手段の一つだと思っているんですけど
抜き付とか者名っていうのを偽善的だって思ってる人に話したくて
あの例えばまあ友達にお誕生日のプレゼントを出しましたのかときにいろんな嗜好を
持って皆私と思うんですね
こうなんだろうなそれこそこの子に完封をもらったから私も会社なきゃとかこの子から
誕プレ欲しいから私もあげとこうと
彼から単純に箱に喜んでほしいとか色々こう思うところがあると思うんですけど
すごく悪い言い方をしたら人は大
見返りをもっと持って誕生日プレゼントとカフェのプレゼントを足していると思うん
ですね
あってその喜んでほしいって言う
その感情においてもよろこ
グっていうかの対応っていうか反応を求めてるじゃないですか
すごく悪く言ったんですよで
でもそうやっていうこともできる起動
その間剤プレゼントを渡すっていう行為を偽善だって思っててなかなかいないと思うん
ですね
でそれと聞くとか署名というのは同じことだと思っていて
って自分がしたことによって相手が喜んでくれたり相手に役に立つっていうことで自分
は満足考えるとか自分もうれしくなるっていうのは同じ感情の循環だと思うんですね
そう考えたら別に熱心に盛況
進行していなくてもできることだと思うしこれでもまだ
茶行活動が毅然的だって思いますかっていうの私は問いたいです
で皆さんに行こう提案なんですけど
最初に行ったそのん
日本のそのは彼もなものを知らないって言われたくないっちゃいの話をしたじゃない
ですか
であのその解決策として私は知識をつけることを
その提唱したいいですね
もっと言ったらオタクになってほしいんですよ
どういうことって思うかもしれないんですけどあの社会問題についてのオタクになって
欲しくてうざい社会問題を波高値しろってわけじゃないんですよ
みんな多分その警告とかジャニーズとかアイドルとカードの好きな人があると思うけど
それ全体を設定わけじゃなくて乗っ自分がニュースを見て興味を持った
トピックに対してその何度イッこのトピックについて
をしてほしいんですねでなんでかっていうと
no 日本のその何ラインとかツイッターのニュースのそのトレンド検索なみたいな
見てもらったら分かると思うけど結構その芸能人の古いソードとかで研究するのに
酒井問題に対してはなかなか言及しないという人が多いと思うんですねそれで別に
私たちの世代だけ
じゃなくて年代かかわらずいることだと思うんですよ
磯野たときに自分たちはあの私たちの中でも sns を頻繁に使うキー認識があると
思うし
他の世代から見ても sns をすごくよく使う
づらいっていう印象があると思うんですよ急い私たちがその車
海問題に興味を持って一人一人が全くとして責任を持ってこの押すことであの
自分のなんだろう岸きてか発覚士気も上がると思うし日本の全体の社会問題に対する
意識やレベルも上がると思うんですよ
でそうなったときに何がいいかって言ったらその社会問題っていうのは正義だったりと
かし方だったりとか
いろんな問題にこう派生して関わってくることだとおっ
の正義に対する興味が結果
たぶんちょっと感心が上がるじゃないですかそうなったらきっと国民一人一人の意見が
反映される
正義ができればいいと思うしあの日本の社会問題に対する引き上がるっていうことは
社会問題を
4室してはいけないっていう認識が広まるっていうことだからその根本的な解決には
つながらないかもしれないけど改善や繋がると思うんですね
だから私は2つの意味でオタクになってほしいっていうのを言いたくて
1個1日本社会を良くするためてもう1個は自分たちが無知ら
言われてしまうのはしょうがないですよ
って高校生だし経験していることだってすごい浅はかたし
あ
言われてしまうのはしょうがないけど
私はデイ者のなんかですねとなり座ってサラリーマンのおじさんよりも私のほうが絶対
カ国件の文書については詳しいっていうと思うしみんなにもうそうなってほしくて
そうなったらだってハイキングはこのないもチラって言われる世の中ってちょっと
変わると思うんですよ
私この問題についてはなったより1
ますよっているわけだからその状態私は目指して欲しくてそうなったな
私たちの売ってるみたいなものも一つずつ薄れていくし
日本社会も良くなるしでいいことしかないじゃんっていうのが言いたいんですねだから
みんなにはオタクになって欲しいなって思って
今日この話をしましたちょっとでも共感してくれたら嬉しいです
ご静聴ありがとうございました